las mejores de la historia así calificó
el presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin
las relaciones con china en una
videoconferencia con su homólogo chino
XIX Putin afirmó compartir la visión de
transformación del panorama geopolítico
que tiene China
en el contexto de creciente extensiones
geopolíticas crece la importancia de la
asociación estratégica ruso china como
factor estabilizador
internacional a la que calificó como
difícil y nada inequívoca y dijo estar
listo para fortalecer los lazos
comerciales como Moscú estamos listos
para construir una cooperación
estratégica con Rusia brindarnos
oportunidades de desarrollo ser socios
globales En beneficio de los pueblos de
nuestros países y en aras de la
estabilidad alrededor del mundo
para Putin la cooperación debe
fortalecerse también en el ámbito
militar sin embargo Aún se muestra
cauteloso a pesar de que china no se ha
sumado a las sanciones internacionales
contra Rusia por la guerra en Ucrania
insta por una solución negociada en el
conflicto desde el inicio de la invasión
rusa Ucrania el 24 de febrero Putin ha
acelerado su giro hacia Oriente para
evadir las duras sanciones económicas
que Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea
han impuesto al kremlin Rusia ha
aumentado casi en 400% su comercio
internacional con dos gigantes asiáticos
India y China con este último los
intercambios superaron los 9 mil
millones de dólares este año y Rusia se
convirtió en el segundo proveedor de gas
en China unas relaciones bilaterales que
deberían consolidarse con una esperada
visita a estado de She a Moscú en la
primavera de 2023